avant de commencer je vous annonce
qu'après un mois complets à la cigale
avec mon spectacle le spectacle de la
maturité
je fais des prolongations au casino de
paris du 7 au 15 février et ensuite en
tournée dans toute la france en suisse
en belgique et au québec en septembre
j'ai hâte de vous y voir prenez vos
places dans la description bon déjà
bonne année ça y est on est en 2020
[ __ ] donc l'an 2000
c'était il ya vingt ans exactement ce
que moi je suis pris un coup de vieux là
mais bon l'occasion est parfaite pour
faire une petite vidéo nostalgique un
petit flash back to the past sur cette
belle période z1000 qui mine de rien est
une grande période un chargé de
l'histoire qu'il ya qu à son charme et
sa poésie
alors moi vu que je suis clairement un
dinosaure de youtube à une sorte de
fossiles d'oiseaux en 2000 j'avais 12
ans j'étais nourri élevés et éduqués
avec que des références de cette part-là
projet connaît pas que ça arrête
et tu dis un truc sur tragédie je te
démarre alors déjà avant un peu de la
mode vestimentaire
accrochez vos pinceaux brève l'échelle
les casquettes von dutch et qu'audiard
comme eight ddp fugu scott ou shot tout
scouts jamais su le dire a pas de trucs
évidemment les baggies défroque
ultra-larges leur attention
la blague préférée des dieux c'était des
tâches élan pour froch et là rire
général au repas de famille
alors le concept du baggy et qu'il
fallait les porter à seebach on voit
tout cas son ya beaucoup d'heures qu'il
portait elle a tellement bas qu'on
pouvait leur fut en fait c'était aussi
la mode du pantalon taille basse qui
essaie de dépasser le string mais bien
dépassée a lancé par cet essai psy ou si
c'était beau et qui suis-je pour juger
en fait je suis mère dans l'univers le
pantacourt l'écolier tatouage que les
meufs météo coup la cravate sur le tee
shirt le piercing au nombril
les buffalos avec des flammes le gloss
fruité et le goûter ton gosse en faisant
un petit bisou à la barre dont je trouve
la fraise les chaussures caterpillar les
bottes ugg ou ugg
personne ne s'est en fait les lunettes
de soleil façon anastasia teintées là ou
si elle façon richard virenque les
mèches de couleur dans les cheveux j'en
ai eu les os qui dévoilait seulement une
épaule les ceintures tout et tout le
monde avait une période et mocky duré
deux semaines et aussi c'était hyper
stylé de mettre une chaîne à son
portefeuille
j'en avais aussi une et j'avais
tellement envie qu'un jour quelqu'un
essaye de piquer mon portefeuille juste
pour rentabiliser le truc bref niveau
style les années 2000 vous ai pas loupé
limite on devrait vous faire un procès
sylar années 2000
vous êtes accusé d'avoir lancé un
certain nombre de modes discutable voire
ridicule qu'est ce que vous avez à dire
pour votre défense
je préfère laisser parler mon avocat
[Musique]
j'ai parfaitement au moins lire votre
dépense le mec qui a écrit sur une
feuille qui donnent bon on rigole mais
on se moque pas trop non plus parce que
on serait parce qu'on est aujourd'hui
sans cette belle période qui nous a
construit maintenant parlons
technologies comme la vidéo est chapitré
clairement j'ai fait craindre une
feuille en fait par mois je pars c'est
des gens qui ont connu le passage de
1999 à 2000 c'est-à-dire d'un millénaire
à l'autre diouf
il ya l'époque on pensait qu'à ce
moment-là précis est d'abord une sorte
de groupe générale de tous les
ordinateurs du monde et on appelait ça
le bug de l'an 2000 sauf que finalement
et ça va passer du r tout va bien
quand elle met ton ordinateur ça faisait
ce bruit et ont utilisé des webcams ce
genre de webcams bien ronde alors
c'était très typique de cette époque qui
passe il vous rappeler de la qualité
d'image que ça faisait en fait un petit
test on va vraiment la branche et des
marques them up et voilà bienvenue dans
les années 2000 avant le son l'image
sont assez pourri mais à l'époque pour
nous c'était un truc de ouf on était
déjà hyper content de se voir et de
s'entendre dans l'ordinateur
donc on critique pas on construit la
vidéo comme ça où on se remet comme ça
leur attention
le claquement de doigt un peu ringard
d'ailleurs j'ai retrouvé quelques vidéos
que je faisais la webcam
à cette époque aujourd'hui est un jour
un peu exceptionnelle puisque je vais
m'en aller d'ici quelques minutes chez
le coiffeur
nous voici après quoi faire bien écoutez
je trouve que ce résultat n'est pas non
plus des plus réjouissants un peu
simpliste un peu mots je peux de la
belle en fait totalement gens rentrent
pas pu parce que c'est ça plante pour
moi les années 2000 c'était vraiment les
années des divx sais pas si vous vous
rappelez alors un divx c'était un cd
gravables sur lequel on mettait un film
en version ultra compressé c'est à dire
en qualité pourrie on se re fourguer des
divx entre nous des cd gravé le tout
dans des pochettes cd complètement
dégueulasse il y avait un petit côté à
coeur au made qui était cool on écoute
émotions sur windows media player
les vrais se rappelle de ses graphismes
il y avait les baladeurs cd pour les
plus riches les ipod
la plupart des gens avaient des lecteurs
mp3 les jeunes de 2020 vous devez rien
capté à cet objet en gros tu branches ça
sur ton ordi comme une clé usb et tu
glisses et dessus des chansons chansons
de stiller son corps et flairer cent
fois sans visage est trop
[Musique]
et autres
tout s'est tu
les détails pour le wallaby qui fini
mais tu matching même passé je me sens
pour toi un truc de dingue je peux même
pas mettre un mot sur sa pointe
d'aigreur chez les gens de montres ton
coeur
[Musique]
c'est depuis les ovales des monnaies
disait alors ce morceau on dirait
vraiment le morceau d'une pub avec leurs
forfaits je me sens enfin libre je peux
courir dans les champs l'acte de bovins
j'en ai plus rien à [ __ ] seulement 29
ans 45 noms jeanne d'arc va tous se
mettre vraiment beaucoup trop après il
ya eu les mini disc les md pas
comprendre accueille la mde c'était un
truc comme ça
ceux qui avaient des lecteurs md c'est
assez rare et du coup ça racontait un
peu à tapas de lecteurs md avec ça c'est
le futur
bientôt tout le monde grâce à cet objet
sera le plus gros bide commercial de
l'histoire alors myspace tout le monde
presque était sur myspace et tout le
monde était par des faux amis avec tom
le créateur de myspace qui avait photo
de profil sur la même et pendant des
années je me suis demandé pourquoi cette
photo en particulier go la table ouais
bah tant j'étais pas prêt c'est bon
c'est pas grave ce pas comme si tu
allais garder cette photo tout t'as vu
c'est clair je pouvais complètement
personnalisée de la page myspace il me
fallait une licence encodage tellement
petit compliqué à faire on devait limite
lire des tutos juste pour changer la
couleur là on peut voir un ch'ti de la
fiction de guitare c'est quand même
possible de personnalisation non parce
qu'on mettait en avant nos meilleurs
amis sur notre page myspace genre
n'était meilleur ami avec offspring et
daft punk et le pire c'est qu'on n'y
croyait un peu
ouais sur myspace je suis pote avec les
daft punk quoi on s'envoie des petits
messages et two way et vous vous dites
quoi je pense en vo des petits messages
tom guillon soit comme une bière normale
quoi
[ __ ] et répondre quoi bas suivant m
écrivent nouvel album bientôt dispo et
voilà c'est une amitié en construction
alors évidemment les skyblogs
chacun avait son petit skyblog
personnalisé sur lequel en poster des
articles on se prenait pour des
écrivains écorché vie chère journal
aujourd'hui je me suis fait larguer
comme une merde
cela faisait trois jours je crois que
j'en dépression les parents et incombe
rendent plus tard en plus j'avais graver
une compil avec les destiny's child tant
pis pour elle cher msn
celui qui ne connaît pas msn ici dehors
je ne veux pas te parler
le logiciel le plus cultes de l'histoire
ouais j'ai dit logiciel web c'était donc
un logiciel pour chatter entre
vote ou entre collègues mais clairement
on avait 12 ans donc il y avait le bon
vieux with ac se mobilisent
j'avais oublié seul mot peut être la
personne ne répondait pas il faut lui
envoyer un with ces bandes armées et
pour chanter les louanges des mécènes il
y avait cette chanson culte de 6 chain
génération msn je voulais
[Musique]
en face
elle rend le
il y avait média vidéo comme netflix
mais parfaitement illégal avait des
films sous titrés en croit tous japonais
et ça a tellement bien marché
le trader a fait de la prison donc ouais
gros cartons ont été déchargés de leur
fils ou nos chansons via des
peer-to-peer tu mettais une semaine à
télécharger de son film avec la
connexion mois à 56 k est très souvent
tombé sur un autre fichier que prévu
c'est de la merde émules en fait les
buzz internet en 2020 c'était
rang d'icône et réchappé 50 euros la
part les blagues sur chuck norris
oui biden parking d'escarres q92 fr
derrière moi je me rappelle encore des
paroles par coeur l'emblème ultime des
années 2000 c'était ça le nokia 33 10 tu
passes d'un rendez compte
j'avais pas fais ça depuis des années
est en fait ces minuscules ces
microscopiques
ce portable a eu une hype ce qu'il
l'avait il était au max tu pouvais jouer
au snake mettre des sonneries connu
changer la coque
bon après j'avais le bon vieux sage m
inconnu chez moi vous auriez un chargeur
de sage nnw 30 26
après jules alcatel one touch 511 alors
on rigole plus du tout je le rappelle
sur la boîte écrit sons polyphoniques
alors je vais écouter à quoi ressemble à
sons polyphoniques on va pas se mentir
on s'est pris une claque
le son est énorme quant aux photos par
fontas téléphone ben ils n'avaient pas
voilà à la place on avait ceux ci des
appareils photo numériques très relou à
transporter ta poche était énorme mais
voilà c'était plein de charme et c'est
vraiment les retraités ça c'est 600
millions de pixels par photo way à quoi
ma vie sexuelle en plus tôt photo ça
donne
alors oui au niveau du pic et il ya
aussi eu le nokia n gage
un mix entre une console et un téléphone
portable et les ventes ça a été un mix
entre échec évident des bons à l'époque
ont kiffé de ouf avec les portables on
se la raconter je te jure avec ça les
gens se la péter comment tu vas toi
alors c'est plus de crédit voit pas ce
qu'il fallait acheter des cartes pour
mettre des minutes d'appels sur ton
téléphone dires mêmes des forfaits dits
textos la tristesse du truc du coup
compte envoyer un texto fallait vraiment
que ça va mieux pour vous je te quitte à
base de textos
elle a appuyé trois fois soit touche
pour faire un ces casses toi pour faire
un sgt 15 minutes à écrire un texto quoi
voilà pourquoi on faisait tout pour
écrire court et c'est comme ça qu'est né
le langage texto
du coup on avait pas mal recours au
téléphone fixe alors on se dit peg le
téléphone portable pour se rappeler le
fixe de teuhpu et le téléphone fixe
s'est tu pouvais pas du tout isolé pour
avoir une discussion perso et du coup tu
as réussi à mettre la capote ou pas
maman tu peux partir à temps je savoir
la suite moi d'ailleurs de nos jours
pour cela rendez-vous on se voit
tellement de messages localisation et
tous que quand il faisait à l'époque il
n'y avait que le téléphone fixe quoi les
gens ils devaient bien programmé leur
rendez-vous à l'avance au rendez vous
mardi 8 février devant la poste
au revoir
puis en 2007 il ya eu le premier iphone
et tout le monde s'en foutent et iphone
ça marchera jamais ça lui nokia les il
ya un temps de sud n'est pas la 3g pas
de flash pas d'applications externes
enfin de la gueule de ji apple là au bon
niveau culture d'être tellement de trucs
que je vais vraiment survolé le sujet
vite fait en gros à la radio la vie à la
télé il y avait qu elle est la femelle
du lièvre dans le vrai pour le petit fan
pacte
kim kardashian était l'assistante de
paraît-il de jeu fusent
ouais c'était les premières téléralité
époque c'était un tout nouveau jeu
n'existait pas tu vois et donc nous
avant ça comme émission de référence
on avait l'habitude il reste un choc
enfin l'émission dont j'étais ultra fan
quand j'étais petit les le nikkei
qui un jour j'avais su que j'aurai ma
propre marionnette dans les mimiques m
les mammouths n'existe plus non remis
ouais j'ai ma propre marionnette dans
les mimiques et moi alors certes
l'émission c'est pas la même qu'à
l'époque c'est un petit poème ultra
plaisir j'ai tellement fier après le
casting est clairement aucun sens
clairement je ne connais pas du tout
rihanna ni par pol bat dont je prononce
très mal le nom là on a parlé des
souvenirs cool mais l année 2007 aussi
plein d'événements marquants beaucoup
moins marrant il ya plein d'événements
qui ont marqué les années 2000 il ya eu
le passage à l'euro au delà du 33 10 et
des petites babioles c'est vraiment une
période comme toutes les périodes va
marquer l'histoire et qui était faite de
plein d'événements de ouf
alors évidemment je n'ai pas pu parler
de tout dans cette vidéo parce que si
j'avais parlé de tout sera fait un
documentaire de trois heures j'ai fait
une petite sélection perso des trucs qui
m'ont le plus marqué et vous qu'est ce
qui vous a marqué dans les années 2000
tout dans les commentaires j'irai lire
ça m'intéresse vraiment ça se trouve on
fera l'épisode 2 qui s'est évidemment
mais tu es un petit pouce en l'air pour
donner de la force envoyé au [ __ ] j'ai
pu creuser bon
[Musique]